I don't want to waste any time for
example the first thing it fascinated me
as you had I'm going way way back to the
beginning you had a great job
hewlett-packard you had a legitimate you
know job I was working on the hottest
product of the day the equivalent
today's hottest iPhone ever right
it was the handheld calculator from
hewlett-packard yeah and you had this
great job and then you said I'm leaving
I'm going out with my buddy Steve Jobs
Ronald Wayne and we're gonna make our
own company called Apple that took guts
a little problematic saying that way
because we had to starts to Apple not
just one start we had a start us a
little partnership with one product just
kind of in the garage just homey stuff
and then we started a real company and
the real company was when I left you
look Packard I see a tough tough
decision for me because I wanted to be
an engineer for life I believe in
engineers everything they do has to work
and that's a type of honesty and I
believe in it and it's learning stuff
right and so I was gonna be an engineer
for life ela Packard never go up the
management chart and I had to convince
myself a company that's like I'm not a
company running person I'm an engineer
and I finally convinced myself I could
start Apple and be an engineer still
right the laboratory just go in the
laboratory and build my stuff well time
will tell if you made the right decision
now we have you know what we found here
this picture of you and Steve Jobs with
the original Apple one and it just takes
you back it's such an amazing photo
that is the first one and and and we
find the first Apple one ad we found
check it out this is the ad for it and
the price look at the price 666 dollars
and sixty six cents why that was me that
was I was eight I was into repeating
digits and it came from I had run the
first dial-a-joke in the San Francisco
Bay Area the highest called single line
number in the United States I was just a
young engineer barely out of college we
had a monopoly phone company only one
answering machine you could lease high
price could barely afford it but it was
in any but it got 2,000 calls a day and
anybody who had a similar number got a
hundred calls a day so I changed the
number and then I tried to make an easy
one two five five five five five five
and the phone company said we're not
assigning on the five thousand bank so I
got to five five six six six six my
first good phone number and then I got a
number with six digits the same in
Cupertino nine nine six nine nine nine
nine for my dial-a-joke and I was into
these good numbers and you could never
get 78 just the same in those days in
San Jose because they wouldn't share any
of the numbers San Francisco had in San
Francisco had seven seven seven seven
seven seven and all those so I got the
good numbers I was into good numbers and
I got two two one one one one one once
on a cell phone and that was very
similar to Pan Am 802 to one one one one
one
I got all these calls and people would
hang up and I discovered I was booking a
flight for myself and in my flight guy I
saw Pan Am's number so the next time I
got a call I said are you calling Pan Am
and she's yes and I said oh we were on a
lunch break what can I do for you my
first wife afraid for two years I
answered every single call on my phone
Pan Am international des Craig speaking
and my friends watch out it's me Steve
and I I play I booked the phoniest
flights and times and I could and I
would tell people you can take the
grasshopper special where you go to
through five different cities up and
down to get out till to Boston or I
would tell them the gamblers special you
fly to Las Vegas you roll the dice if
you get a seven the next leg is free I
have so much fun but after bike about
you're ruining people's live but
how did I not get caught yeah it would
it be easy for if somebody realized who
they called by mistake and set the
police on you
so after two weeks I got that scared and
I said so for the next two years I would
book the phoniest flights I could and
then say I'm just pranking you know I'm
not really paying in do you have and
then they love that but but so so so we
have the apple the Apple one computer
and we're gonna all get paid $500 per
board wholesale by the store that was
local and low add thirty percent to that
had a third to it and that comes out 667
I know six 6666
like it's it's a sign of the devil
I don't know if they were complaints but
we did hear from somebody and Steve and
I didn't know 666 was any sign yeah no
we didn't even know yeah there you know
it's so interesting there's been two
Steve Jobs movies the one by Aaron
Sorkin showed that you guys obviously
cared a lot about each other but you had
a combative relationship was that fair
did you think that was a fair depiction
the competitive relationship was totally
subtle I never once confronted Steve
Jobs in life I would never say anything
negative film you should do this I would
not even do that to a friend because I'm
real soft very very soft but those
issues were going on in the company that
were put in my voice and one time I did
make this a statement similar to one of
them to our president John Sculley like
blaming him for having had a
shareholders meeting hardly mentioning
the Apple two and all that but two
people wanted to quit right so you did
have a third off once
you